[Music]
hi Aaron how are you I'm doing great
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up awesome well my dad moved in
with us a couple of years ago and no
longer works due to health issues got
stage-four cancer well he while he was
working
you know purchased a car and getting
back and forth to work to get rid of his
old clunker and you know that he's not
working with the car the insurance meds
and things like that you know it's no
security is the only income that this at
this time so that's not obviously not
gonna cover and I know he's you know
getting a little behind on stuff we're
trying to help him out on someone is you
know if we should just go ahead and
pause on that snowball and start working
off to kind of help
how about his situation kind of as I
mean if he does live with us at the time
no no as one family just kind of work on
yeah no no I would not pay his debts I
think it's wonderful that you're giving
him a place to live and you're taking
care of him while he's fighting cancer
but there's no point in paying his debts
it doesn't serve any purpose at all
Heena sell the car doesn't he yeah we
currently have a for sale just have I'm
getting hits on that song and rental in
the price make it a little more
marketable yeah absolutely
how much other data is he got just
basically the I think it's just a car
and a storage unit
he had a storage unit with a bunch of
stuff in it yes well I guess we need to
sell off the stuff and get rid of
storage unit and use that money right
yeah okay that's fairly easy yeah so so
that was I mean if you sell the car and
you sell the stuff out the storage unit
he doesn't have any expenses if he's
living with you I think he medical stuff
yeah and don't sign for that right I
mean that's it I mean you can take care
of him without you know you getting on
the hook for a million dollars or the
cancer treatments
right and so um you know that there's
don't blur the lines on what taking care
of him means you see what I'm saying
when you go over and start stepping into
his financial obligations and taking
those on that's a whole lot different
than taking care of him while he's you
know fighting a cancer fight oh and how
old is he he'll be 65 next block okay
and you said stage for what's the
prognosis it was it was three to ten
initially but that was I think before
they saw the bone scans and so kind of
where where all was spread so I think
that's that's kind of three to ten is
definitely a little progressive I think
months three to ten months no I'm sorry
it was it was three to ten years I'm
thinking about three years as special
that yeah okay all right I'm sorry
sorry you guys are having to walk
through this the least of his problems
then our cars and storage units but to
relieve stress you can clean out those
two things and get rid of the helped him
get rid of those two obligations without
you having to sign up for his debts that
makes sense yes I mean yes you take care
of him he's your dad and that's
wonderful and I think I want to
completely hear you you know embrace
that and I'm so sorry you guys are
facing this is such a a gut wrenching
thing to go through emotionally okay
now then let's deal with what happens
someday we all pass away what happens
when he passes away if he has debt and
he passes away it doesn't get paid but
if you start taking it on then his debt
survives him and you are now obligated
so yeah and so uh a real cold way of
saying and I don't want you to
misunderstand my lack of compassion
because it's not one I've gone I hear
yeah I know what you guys are fatty but
but make sure you take care of him but
let his debt pass away when he does does
that make
because it you know if you die and you
owe money and there's no assets which is
his situation they don't get paid they
don't get paid and so that's what I mean
by it's there's no reason let's do the
best we can do to get this off of him
too but but you know scale of one to ten
this debt stuff is a 1 and cancer is a
10 right right in terms of things to
worry about things to be stressed about
or whatever or whatever so that's I want
to concentrate on that but I'm so glad
you're there for him and that you've got
he's got a place and you know you can
take care of him and those kinds of
things and it's just a it's the way it
should be so hey thanks for the call